à en avoir absolument ras-le-bol car
chaque élection on vous refasse le coup
du barrage à l'extrême droite et bien
cette année on va se payer le luxe de
leur barrer la route dès le premier tour
la qualification pour le second tour le
député du Nord Adrien catenin c'est les
soutiens de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il croit
de plus en plus ces derniers jours le
leader de la France insoumise ne cesse
de grimper dans les sondages pour
atteindre jusqu'à 15% des intentions de
vote de quoi redonner espoir aux
militants là on y est on est
au niveau du sondage on est troisième on
va y arriver on y arrivera c'est obligé
la marche pour la sixième république
organisée dimanche à Paris a été une
démonstration de force pour Adrien
cadenas le numéro 2 de la France
insoumise veut désormais rassembler plus
largement à gauche
il y a des dispersions qui auraient pu
qui est peut-être peuvent encore être
évité par exemple le Parti communiste
français nous avons été candidats avec
eux en 2012 en 2017 90% de nos votes
sont communs à l'Assemblée beaucoup
comprennent mal que ce qui a été
possible non sans un certain succès en
2012 en 2017 ne l'est plus en 2022 alors
que on est aux portes du second tour
mais pour l'heure le vote communiste ne
suffira pas à se qualifier pour le
second tour à 5 points devant Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a le rassemblement
national désormais principal adversaire
des insoumis ce qui va faire face à
Marine Le Pen c'est de montrer que
Marine Le Pen concrètement c'est au
niveau au niveau de ces politiques
économiques c'est la même chose que
Macron c'est à dire si on enlève les
aspects et de sécurité elle fait elle
fait une politique pour les plus riches
et la même façon donc en fait la seule
voie potentielle pour le peuple et pour
changer la vie des gens c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon des militants déterminés à ne
pas revivre le même scénario qu'en 2017
ils ont désormais 19 jours pour faire la
différence